europe's digital economy data privacy
and suspected electronic eavesdropping
by u.s intelligence services were
highlights as eu leaders met in brussels
the leaders pledged to bring down
digital borders visible for example
through online shopping or mobile phone
roaming charges and to encourage
investment in high-speed broadband and
cloud computing
they also vowed to improve trust between
european citizens and online providers
and to ensure that people have better
control over their personal data
on transatlantic data privacy france and
germany planned to seek talks with the
united states on intelligence gathering
methods and they welcomed other eu
partners to join them
heads of state and government underlined
the close relationship
between europe and the united states
and the value of that partnership
they expressed their conviction that the
partnership must be based on respect and
on trust
including as concerns the work and
cooperation
of secret services
on economic matters the leaders
discussed ways to strengthen the banking
union and keep up momentum on the eu's
roadmap for economic and monetary union
as well as to bolster growth and
confidence in the euro
they expressed determination to tackle
youth unemployment and improve the
availability of finances for small and
medium-sized businesses
preventing tragedies in the
mediterranean was also high on the
agenda the leaders agreed that
determined action must be taken
they want to address the root causes by
working with countries that asylum
seekers leave or transit leaders also
want to step up the fight against human
trafficking they said decisions on
better protecting would-be immigrants
would be taken at their next meeting in
december finally they're hopeful that
they can take major steps forward at the
eastern partnership summit in vilnius
next month they urged ukraine to make
more progress notably on selective
justice